what do you ask of me there's a monster
on our Eileen terrorizing her people I
have felt an evil spirit I sense
something was amiss but why should I
help you because we love her Island and
we need your help
what is this terror that you speak of
pineapple head an idol was sealed in the
darkness of a cave away from the moon's
light and power I let him out and he now
has a piece of the moon itself what you
interfere with the acts of the gods we
didn't realize great goddess I believe
you can help us here
fire is my Dominion but I hold sway with
the god of the sea and the god of
Earth's creatures does that mean you can
help us you together possess all that
you need as long as you believe what do
we need to do
draw him to Hanoi Abu Bay and I will
have some friends waiting for you
pineapple head draws his power from the
moon which must be ceased cut off the
moon um maybe you know realized that's
just an astronaut costume no way he can
actually get up to the moon and do that
if this dark spirit carries a small moon
you must take that back or his power
will continue to grow
[Music]